Evet Merhabalar herkese
kıymetli arkadaşlar öncelikle Güzide
okullarımızdan güzide bir kaç
okulumuzdan biri olan Sabancı
Üniversitesi'nde bu güzel organizasyon
için özellikle teşekkür ediyorum Korona
döneminde Bence herkese iyi geldi hala
gelecek hala bilim konuşabilme konusunda
ısrarımıza Ayriyeten saygı duyuyorum bu
günlerde en çok eksikliğini
hissettiğimiz şey olsa gerek dünya
değişiyor Arkadaşlar bu değişime dair
pek çok içerik oldu Ben başından beri
programı takip etme fırsatı buldum
Felsefe ile başladık diyetle devam
ettiniz ne yediğiniz kıymetli Tabii ki
Daha sonrasında bu girişimcilik
alanındaki konuşmayı da çok ziyadesiyle
beğendim ve hemen çok da kıymetli dostum
ardından bak geri dinledik o Alperen
hanım da tüm gelişimine bir yandan
dışarıdan şahit olduğum için böyle bir
teleks konuşmasında ayperim bugün
geldiği durumu izlemek de benim için
Ayriyeten keyifli oldu pek çok kereler
platformunda beyin anlatma fırsatım oldu
yaklaşık 20 yıldan fazladır Bu alanla
ilgiliyim ben ama
her geçen gün biraz daha sıkıntı artıyor
Bu bildiklerimden midir gördüklerimden
midir
anlattıklarımdan mı yoksa
anlatamadıklarımdan mı bunun taktiğini
size bırakacağım dünya değişiyor
arkadaşlar dünya sürekli değişirken
insan ne kadar değişiyor işte bir sürü
değişim gördünüz hep beraber ama ne
kadar insana dair Bugün aslında biraz
bunlardan bahsedeyim istiyorum yani
insanda Dünya ile birlikte dönüşebiliyor
mu değişebiliyor mu canlılık acaba
zamanın ruhuna eşlik edebilen bir şey mi
buna hepinizle birlikte Bugün bir
değerlendirelim bugün geldiğimiz noktayı
nasıl yöneteceğiz Geleceği nasıl inşa
edeceğiz birlikte konuşalım istiyorum
aslında birkaç tane slaytta getirdim
Size bunları paylaşmak için bakalım
birlikte biraz da slaytlar üzerinden
devam edelim şimdi Eski dünya
anlatacağım Öncelikle size Eski dünya
Eski dünyadan kastım dünyanın eski hali
Çünkü neden bizim için önemli Biz o
dünyaya ait canlılar olarak Dizayn
edildik Yani bugün popüler konulardan
biri
hemen şöyle bir
şey benzetmesini çok seviyorum Eğer
evrenin yaratılışı 365 gün olsaydı insan
sadece insanlık sadece onun son 14
saniyesinde var olacaktı yani son 14
saniyede bir yılla karşılaştırıldığında
son 14 saniye yani istatistiksel olarak
ne kadar anlamlıyız o tartışılır dünya
üzerindeki değerimiz anlamımız
Tartışmaya açık ama bizler için
Tartışmaya açık değil Neden Çünkü biz
insan türü olarak Doğada bir farklılık
barındırdığımızı düşünüyoruz Aslında ne
geliyorsa fırsatta sıkıntı da tamam
farklılıktan kaynaklanıyor Ama şunu
Öncelikle söylemek istiyorum Bu organ bu
organ yaklaşık 2 milyon yıl önce yapıldı
Hadi yuvarlıyorum bir milyon yıl önce
yapıldı Ondan sonrasında çok da ciddi
bir genetik değişim türleri arasında ki
Aile olduğumuz homosapi Çok ciddi bir
genetik değişim olmadı aslında ilginç
bir şeyle bugün konuşmaya başlamak
istiyorum
göbeklitepe'de doğan bir çocukla bir
milyon yılda demeyeceğim Hadi tarihi
bildiğimiz kısımdan başlatalım
göbeklitepe'de doğan bir çocukla Maslak
Acıbadem'de doğan bir çocuk arasında
hiçbir fark yok arkadaşlar genetik
olarak hiçbir fark yok ve Bu organın Bu
organın genetik temeli Sizi ancak Mağara
Adamı yapabilir Hadi seksistli olması
mağara insanı diyelim ben biraz daha
kadınların tarafını tutarım genelde
biliyorsunuz beyinle ilgili konularda
mağara insanı olmak için mağara insanı
olmak için genetik kodumuz müsait ve
Aslında mağara adamının genel tutum
davranışlarını söylediğinde aramızda ne
kadar mağara adam olduğunu Siz de fark
edeceksiniz bencildirler kendi
çıkarlarını düşünürler en önemli şey
onlar için hayatta kalmaktır kendi
hayatta kalma ve çıkarları için
başkalarına zarar vermekten çekinmezler
eğitimsiz bir beyin bunu yapabilir
genetik materyal seni hayatta tutacak
kadar bak çok net söylüyorum seni
hayatta tutacak kadar bir beyni dünyaya
gelirken sana teslim ediyor Onun dışında
çok fazla bir içerik yok bu dünyada
nasıl bir insan olacağımız
homo sapiensin ilkel versiyonundan
bahsetmiyorum gelişmiş bir insan olup
olamayacağımız da yine aslına bakarsanız
bu ilkel organ içerisinde yüklediğimiz
bilgilerle çok alakalı nihayetinde
hepinizin çok iyi bildiğini düşündüğüm
insanın genetik materyali nasıl ki
evrenin tüm bilgisini taşıyorsa
beyin de dünya üzerindeki gelişmiş
Gelişmekte olan bütün bilgiyi içeriği
sizler için taşıyıp içselleştirme
kudretine sahip Kusura bakmayın Hemen
şuradan bir
aynur'umu açmıştım ekran koruyucusu
girdi atlamayalım onu da
Evet
ve nihayetinde beyne kodladığımız
bilgiler yani evrendeki o temel canlılık
bilgisini Çok Ötesinde Sen bu dünyaya
geldi bu dünyada nasıl bir canlı
olacaksın bunun öğrenme vasıflı Aslında
bizim nasıl insanlar olacağımızı
belirliyor temelde beynin ne iş
yaptığını anlatacağım size temelde beyin
duyuları aracılığıyla gelen bakın
duyguları arasında gelen verileri
karşılaştırabiliyor arkadaşlar başka
hiçbir şey yapmaz verileri karşılaştırma
yeteneğe yasak bütün öğrenme yolculuğu
aldığı verileri bakın veri alamazsa bir
kere öğrenemez verinizi kısıtlayan veri
akışınızı kısıtlayan her şey öğrenmenizi
bloke ediyor demektir beyine veri
gitmezse gözlerden beri gitmezse
kulaklardan dokun şuradan bir yere
gitmezse beyin için hiç varlığından söz
etmek dahi mümkün değil bu verileri
ışığında bu verileri ışığında aldığı
içerikleri saklama karşılaştırma ve
sonra çıktıya dönüştürüyor Bu bazen
tamamen hayal ürünü bir şey olabilir
bazen Kolunuzu kaldırmak gibi motor bir
hareketli olabilir nihayetinde girdileri
var o giren verileri kıyaslama saklama
onlardan yola çıkarak çıktı verme işte
bunun da neye dönüşeceğini söyledim bu
yeteneklere sahip beyin
yetenekleriyle iyi bir organdır
diyemeyiz bakın Çünkü yetenek ne demek
yetenek bunu yapıyor karşılaştırma
yeteneğin var Peki sen ne ile Neyi
karşılaştırıyorsun hafızanda saklama
yeteneğin var peki sen neyi hafızanda
tutuyorsun çıkarım yapma yeteneğin var
Sen hangi bilgileri pozitif hangileri
negatif değerleyeceksin ve çıkarırım
yapacaksın Bu Kompleksi de Aslında sizin
bu yeteneklerinizden çok daha kıymetli
buna Biz yetkinlik diyoruz yani
beyninizin birtakım yetenekleri var
Acaba sen onu Etkin kullanıyor musun
Bunun için çok konvansiyonel bir örnek
getirdim yanında
bir sürü farklı ülkede örnek var tabii
Ben Türkiye'de Hollanda'ya kıyaslamak
istiyorum Hollanda'nın ekilebilir tarım
arazisi bizim 25'te birimiz kadar
Arkadaşlar slaytlarda hepiniz
görüyorsunuz 25 kat daha yetenekliyiz
demektir Bakın size bunu metaforla
anlatayım istiyorum çünkü yeteneğin çok
övüldüğü bir parttayız sanki yetenekli
olmak iyi bir şeymiş gibi Buyurun size
yetenek 25 kat daha yetenekliyiz biz
ama Hollanda bizden bizden Türkiye
cumhuriyeti'nden buradaki veriler
ışığında söylüyorum 5 kat daha fazla
para kazanıyor o yukarıdaki 25'i burada
yuvarlamış durumdayım farkındayız hak
geçmesin diye O zaman biz Hollanda'dan
25 kat yetenekteyiz Hollanda bizden
125 kat akıllı demektir Arkadaşlar biz
25 kat zekiyiz onlar 125 kat akıllı
demektir bakın Paradoks burada yani
senin ne kadar yetenekli olduğun ne
kadar Yetkin olduğuna karşılıklı denk
gelmiyor yani senin hani çok genç
nüfusumuz fazla onu Etkin kullandım şu
anlamı yok Ben çok zekiyim Pratik Zeka
müzik Etkin kullanmıyorsan hiçbir anlamı
yok buna yetkinlik deniyor aslında
beyniniz bir takım yeteneklerle Dünyaya
Geliyor sen o yetenekleri Yetkin bir
şekilde kullanabilecek misin dünyadaki
insanın yolculuğu bu Tabi insan bu yolu
yürürken bu yolculuğu yürürken Aslında
bakarsanız hediye edilmiş organla
yetinmiyor Nihayetinde benim Beynimin
olmasından Daha önemlisi benim Beynimin
içerisine göbeklitepe'den Maslak
Acıbadem bugünkü çocuğa oradan buraya
kadar insanlık nasıl bir yol katetti Ben
Beynimin içerisine bunu aktarabilirsem
yani yeni Doğan'a Eğer bu yolculuğu
aktarabilirsem O zaman o çocuk bir kere
Bu yüzyılın çocuğu olma hakkını
kazanıyor biz buna eğitim diyoruz eğitim
medeniyetin insanlık tarihinin bize
sunduğu avantajlı bilgileri yeni doğan
canlıya aktarıp bu yüzyıla onu
getirmektir arkadaşlar Eğer bunu
yapmıyorsa bir eğitim sistemi o zaman
eğitim vermenin çok bir esprisi yok
eğitimini niye verdiğimiz onu Bazen
araçla amacı karıştırırız bazen problemi
odaklanıp sonra bir çözüm bulur sonra
çözümü o kadar çok kafayı takıyoruz ki
problemi unutma ihtimalimiz var Bunu da
burada hatırlatmış olalım nihayetinde
bir beyninizin olması değil onu bu
yüzyıla getirmeniz çok değerliydi Ancak
bu şekildeki beyinlere Tabii ki dünyayı
iyiliğe götürecek iyiye götürecek
kaliteli içerikler üretecek beyinler
diyebiliriz tabi hepsi iyiye götürüyor
mu kötüye gidenlere de müdahale edecek
onları da yönetecek onlardaki eksik
vicdanı tamamlayacak Çünkü maalesef
toplumun belli bir oranı %10 kadarı
diyebiliriz dürtüsel bir şekilde insan
beyni vasfı kazanamıyor maalesef insan
yetenekleri var ama insanın kontrol
becerisi bir türlü o insanlarda
gelişmiyor sosyopatlar psikopatlar çok
idealist hırslı tipler Yani bunlar üç
aşağı yukarı aynı familyadandır
nihayetinde bunların dünyaya nereye
götüreceği konusunda kimsenin Fikri
olamaz kendilerini dahi Fikri olduğunu
zannetmiyorum Çünkü Ne dedim ben size
Eğer bir insan eğitilemezse eğitilebilir
değilse ya da eğitilmemişse ya da
eğitimi bir şekilde reddetli ise bünyesi
almadıysa o zaman insanları ne
yapacağını biz bilemeyiz ilkel insanın
temel dürtüleri vardır Kendini hayatta
tutmak Kendi menfaatleri için herkesi
görmezden gelebilmek Onun dışındaki
insanlarla bu dünyayı daha iyi bir yer
yapmak mümkün o insanlara da vicdan
katmak için büyük kitlelerin gücünü
kullanmak Tabii ki çok kıymetli onu da
hatırlamış olalım birlikte olmak bugünün
dünyasında birlikte olmak bir arada
olmak hepimiz Hiçbirimiz hepimizden
akıllı olamayız demek deseninizi
yönetimlere geçip Merkezi bir Otoritenin
ötesinde Hepimizin yeri geldiğinde
üzerine bu sorumluluğu aldığı yepyeni
sistemler yeni dünya düzeneklerine
karşımıza Çıkacak O yüzden lütfen
sizlere de tavsiyem bu alanda zihninizi
geliştirin bu alanda Zihni geliştirmek
ne biliyor musun benim yaptığımdan çok
Bizim yaptığımız önemli demek EGO
sistemden ekosisteme geçmek demek yani
birlikte olma fikrini Ben olup benim
menfaatlerim benim çıkarlarımın önüne
taşıyabilmek demek aslında böyle
beyinler için bu hayat daha anlamlı bir
şekilde yaratık yaşanılabilir daha fazla
anlam katılabilir nihayetinde Ben bugün
size tabii ki beyni nasıl
kodlayacağınızı anlatmaya geldim beynin
bir etten sütten bir organ olmadığını
Efendim İşte bu organ kilosu 300 lira
500 lira diyebileceğimiz bir değerden
ibaret olmadığını bugünün dünyasındaki
değer kriterlere içinde ne var ya da kaç
lira eder Eğer kriterlerin ötesinde siz
onu ne kadar etkin kullandınız ve etkin
bir şekilde planlayıp programlandınız
onu hatırlatmak isterim bu Etkin
programlama da kullanacağınız içerik
yazılım veriler nereden kaynaklanacak
Tabii ki veri tabanlarından hemen size
Dünya
geleceğin iş modellerinde füturoff
capson 2025 raporunu getirdim yani
2025'e kadar biz nasıl bir insan kaynağı
yetkinliği Arıyoruz diye Şimdi bu
gençler böyle yeni şeyleri çok seviyor
tabii ki ben de haklı olarak onlara
getirdim ama siz de genç değilsiniz
artık Çünkü neden dünyanın hızına
baktığımızda iyi kötü son 10 yıldır
kariyerinizle ilgili uğraşıyorsunuz Ben
son 10 yılda bu listedeki değişimleri
getirdim size bakalım Siz adapte
olabildiniz mi yaşlılara zaten hiç lafım
yok 2015 yılındaki liste Bu arkadaşlar
2015 yılında en önemli şey karmaşık
problem çözümü müzakere becerisi
kontrolü aktif dinleme gibi bir takım
parametreler var yaratıcı da olursa iyi
sonra bakın yaratıcılık pat diye yukarı
çıkmış listede Biz bunu anlatıyorduk
yıllardır bu konsepti anlatıyor ben bu
başlıkların her birini bir hafta
anlatıyorum baktığınızda büyük
şirketlere beyin anlatırken nihayetinde
yaratıcılık öne geçmiş yaratıcılık çok
önemli yaratıcı falan var kalite
kontrolü gitmiş Artık makineler yapacak
onu diye duygusal zeka gelmişti yerine
aktif sonra gittin niye makinalar botlar
vesaire onun yerine de bilişsel esnek
diye bir şey gelmişti Ben yıllarca bir
liste resimdeki ne olduğunu bilen var mı
diye sordum 2020 yılına kadar 3 kişi
görmedim bilimsel esnek gibi bilen ki
yıllık totalde herhalde yıllık 100 bine
yakın İnsanlar bir şekilde temas
ediyorum bu konuları konuşmak için peki
Ben daha bu Listenin bu listeden
dönüşümüne daha anladık anlayamadık Ne
oluyor ne bitiyor derken biz Korona ile
uğraşırken 2020'nin son günlerinde ne
çıktı biliyor musunuz bu liste listede 9
değişti arkadaşlar bakın Sen ortaokula
başladığında Bu liste ile eğitim
alıyordun modern dünyada veri odaklı
eğitimden bahsediyorum sonra Listenin
sonuna doğru bu listeye tabi oldun Sen
daha üniversiteyi bitirmeden Senden bunu
isteyecekler
Sen de yaşlandın Eğer bu hızı ayak
uyduramıyorsan gençliğin Yaşla bir
alakası yok ayak uydurma ile değişmek
gücüyle bir alakası var Unutma bu
maddeleri size Sadece başlık olarak
söyleyeceğim ki üzerine düşünün diye
bakın problem çözme bitti Eskiden
insanın beyninden önemli yeteneği
problem çözmekte artık diyor ki sen
Analitik düşünmüyorsan yeniliğe katkın
Yoksa seni çözdüğünü program Seni
ilgilendirir Beni ilgilendirmez aktif
öğrenme yani öğrenme ve
öğrenme stratejisi en önemli Ben
yıllardır konuşmacıyım daha şu konuşmam
hiç satın alınmadı arkadaşlar ki
Türkiye'nin en çok konuşan
konuşmacılarından biri olarak bunu
Kimseye anlatamadım da şu kimsenin
umurunda değil Yani ne olduğunu merak
ediyorlar nasıl yapılacağı konunda
gayret sarf edelim Bunlar kafa yoralım
yok nasıl yapacağını gidip söylerseniz
danışmanlık alabilirler ama kendimiz
öğrenelim yoktu ki artık öğrenmeyen
kendi kendine öğrenmeyen geleceğe
gidemez
kritik düşünme çok önemli karmaşık
problem çözelim 3 sıraya gelmiş kritik
düşünmek çok önemli ama analizi olmazsa
dedikodu olur Bunu unutmayın yaratıcılık
da mutlaka dönüşüm gücüyle ölçülecek
liderlik sosyal etkisiyle ölçülecek
dediğim gibi çok çetrefilli konular ama
bilin isterim sadece insan Gelecekte bir
anlam ifade etmeyecek teknolojiyi
bedenine katan
teknolojiyi Zihnine katan diyeceğim
Devamını sonra başka zamanlarda mutlaka
gene benden dinleyeceksiniz yılmaz'lık
stres tolerans'ta başka arkadaşlarımıza
çok güzel anlatıyor Bunlar sos skillalar
bunlar hiç unutmayacağız mutlaka sürekli
bir anda Zihni esnek tutup Zihni daha
etki kullanmaya dair içerikler bunlar ve
ben burada fikir üretmeyi çok kıymetli
buluyorum ama fikir kendi başında çok da
bir şey değil ne olur duygusal zeka 15
sırada artık o farkındaysanız eski bilgi
eski kitap eski Instagram'da paylaşılan
çok değerli bilgiler teyzenin kızının
okuduğu kitapla değil veriyle
seçebilirsin çok aktüel olarak
Arkadaşlar bir şey kitaba yazıldıysa
Zaten üzerine 15 sene geçmiştir 10 sene
geçmiştir unutmayın o yüzden yeni
verilerle geliştirmenizi kendinizi
dönüştürmenizi istiyorum Eğer bu hızı
ayak uy
duramazsak Yani çok da bir anlamı yok
klişelerle hayatınıza devam edersiniz
buzda o Buzdağı olmadan sunum olmaz diye
araya koydum Bence artık yeni Dünyada
hiçbir anlamı yok nihayetinde kurduğumuz
ağlar kurduğumuz ağdaki dengeler benim
yaptığım değil bizim ortaya çıkardığımız
değerler dönüştürme gücümüz tam olarak
bu kitlesel gücümüzün arkasında O yüzden
artık kendinle uğraşmaktansa Hepimiz
birlikte daha verimli değer odaklı
işlerle uğraşalım fikirleri beni çok
heyecanlandırır ve yeni nesilde bunu
duydukça daha da büyük gıpta diyorum
Tabii dünyanın genelini kavrayan bir
Yeni Kuşak çok daha değerli bunun da
örneklerini kısmen görüyoruz artık
annelerinizin anlattıkları Romanların
bile hikayelerin bile masalları bile
yeni dünyada bir karşılığı yok
arkadaşlar o yüzden de annelerinizi
babalarınızı sevin ama onları sevdiğiniz
için onların söylediklerim çok daha
ötesini görebilen çocuklar olmaya Özen
gösterin yaşınızdan bağımsız bunu bence
genç kaç yaşında olduğunuzda değil
dönüşebilme gücünüzle alakalıdır Tabii
ki beyindeki bağlantı çok kıymetli son
dakikalara girdiğim şu anda size bu
bağlantıları nasıl geliştireceksiniz
ondan da bahsetmeyi uygun görüyorum bir
beynin gelişmesi çok değerli bunun için
öğrenmek lazım ama öğrenmek çok da bir
işe yaramayacak göreceksiniz çünkü
unutacaksınız
unuttuğunuz şeyleri tekrar
etmeyecekseniz hiç öğrenmeyin arkadaşlar
ve tekrar ettiğiniz şeylerin sizde
ukalalık yerine gerçekten dönüşüm
yaratmasını istiyorsanız mutlaka hayatın
içinde onları uyguluyor olmanız lazım
bakın buraya kadar öğren tekrar uygulama
bunu başkası yapamazsın yani çok büyük
bir hata yapıyoruz bence endüstrinin
büyük bir kısmı bu hatamızı karşıdan
tahrik etmek için oluyor sanki birileri
bize öğretebilir gibi bizim yerimize
tekrar edebilir gibi olamaz öğrenmek
tekrar etmek uygulamak bireyin
sorumluluğunda sonra iyi bir yerde olmak
önemli üçüncü konuşmacıydı zannediyorum
nerede olduğunuzun bir önemi yok dedik
Gerçekten yok Eğer senin ne olduğununla
ilgili bir gerçeğin yoksa biz
zannediyoruz iyi bir işe girersek İyi
bir üniversiteye iyi bir lokasyonda
olursak bu işler yolunda gider kısmen
bir etkisi olabilir ama kesinlikle senin
oraya Etkinden daha önemli değil Ve
ondan sonra liderin bize katkısı Tabii
kıymetli iyi liderler gördün dünya
iyiliği derler de görecektir eminim
bakın burada önemli olan şey şu senin
üzerine düşeni yaparsan iyi bir takım
olursan liderin sürece olumlu olumsuz
etkisi çok azdır Ama eğer Sen üzerine
düşeni yapmazsan birlikte yaptığınız
şeye İnanmazsan o zaman bütün suçu da
liderlerin üzerine yüklemek kolay
olabilir tarih Buna da şahit oldu
nihayetinde bakın başarılı olmak için
bunun fotoğrafını çekin duvarınızı asın
Bence çocuklarınıza abilerinize
ablalarınıza gösterin bunu yapan herkes
başarılı oldu ama sadece
olamazsınız hazır tedesteyken bunu da
rahatlıkla söylemek lazım pek çok teleks
ile konuşmuş biri olarak bilgilenmek çok
kıymetli ama esas yolculuk Ondan sonra
başlıyor hiçbir yarım Yolculuk tam
manasıyla istediğiniz hedefe size
ulaştırmayacak ne kadar sürede başarılı
olurum sorusunun çok yanıtını vermeyi
isterdim Ben de çok bilmiş pek çok insan
gibi en az onlar kadar Bunu söylemeye
Arzularım ama maalesef bildiğimiz diğer
taraftaki nöro sayısı bilgileri bunu
kısıtlıyor o kadar Farklıyız ki herkes
için çok farklı bu bilgi bir tane yanıtı
var bunun süresi yok ama adı var Eğer
ben bu süreci sabırla gelirsem o koca
kişisel gelişim literasyonu bir tane
Arkadaşlar bir tane anahtar kelimesi var
sabret diyorsanız başarırsınız henüz
başaramadıysanız yeterince
sabretmemişsiniz demektir Eğer biri
sizden daha başarılı ise bilin ki O
sizden daha sabırlı olduğu için
aklınızın bir kenarında kalsın istedim
ben hepinizin süper kahramanı
potansiyelin hep çok inandım Çünkü bir
beyniniz var ve beyinlerin birbirinden
farklı Kesinlikle donanımsal değil
Unutmayın yazılımsal bu yazılımda Bunu
geliştirmek için üzerinize aldığınız
sorumluluk
ve dünya üzerinde değer yaratmak için
fark yaratmak için üzerinize aldığınız
sorumluluk gücünüzün temel kaynağı
diyorum beni dinlediğiniz için hepinize
çok teşekkürler arkadaşlar görüşmek
dileğiyle